(Engine revving)
(Police sirens)
They found us.
♪♪
Justin:
Mosquito Coast was written by
my Uncle Paul.
Who I'm the middle namesake of
him, "Justin Paul Theroux."
The main character is played by
Justin Theroux.
Paul:
My nephew, sometimes he calls
himself "Justin Theroux."
(Chuckle) It's a French name,
it's "Theroux."
You want me to say we had a
bond?
Yes, I do!
Margot:
We had a bond!
I remember this book came out in
the early to mid-80's
when I was a kid.
Justin:
I actually read it maybe a
couple of years after it came out.
This thing reeks of nepotism,
but my manager said they're
doing "Mosquito Coast."
I said, "Oh, let' s track it."
And then I read it and fell in
love with it
and then I was actually actively
pursuing it.
I didn't know that he was
auditioning.
Paul:
I didn't know that he was
involved in it.
Paul:
I didn't even know that he had a
great passion for the book.
I'm really delighted that he did
it.
Paul:
And there are some lines that
are not in the book that are in the series
that Justin has channeled from
family history.
That's a problem, what's the
solution?
♪♪
It's hard to give a little
family background
without giving a lot of family
background.
Justin:
But the character of Allie Fox
in the book is based loosely
Justin:
on multiple family members.
One of them I'd say safe to say
is my grandfather Albert Theroux,
who was a very industrious man.
Not everything can be fixed,
Dad.
Of course it can.
In the book, Allie Fox is
driving himself.
The Allie Fox of the series,
he's a man pursued.
(Police sirens)
It's the same spirit with a
different setting.
(Helicopter engine)
Justin:
The character of Allie Fox is a
person who's
Justin:
genuinely trying to give his
children a better life.
And his family a better life.
Paul:
In a way it has come full circle
that I was writing about my
family.
And now, a member of my family
is in it.
♪♪
So where next?